you're not good enough your thighs are
disgusting
that leotard doesn't look right on you
because it doesn't pull you in
i was going five over the scales and i
remember having to go into the fitness
gym
constantly for about seven eight hours
for two days it just got to the point
where i was
always like scared i had to train in
ankle weights
so i would know next time that that's
how it would feel if i put on weight
gymnasts having their hair pulled being
pushed
um and we're talking about you know 10
year old girls being pushed around by
a fully grown adult
these individuals tell a story of a
culture of bullying
fear and discrimination in british
gymnastics
over a period spanning four decades
a period which has seen great britain
transform from podium spectators
to a medal-winning force on the world
stage
from beth tweddle to max whitlow
gymnastics is one of the jewels in the
crown of british olympic sport
here's a third big symbol but now it's a
time of reckoning
this week the sports head coach amanda
redding has been temporarily suspended
over bullying claims an independent
review into allegations of mistreatment
within gymnastics has formally begun
and now sky news can reveal that several
gymnasts are pursuing a group action
legal case it could be the most damaging
bloat yet to the system
so how did one of sports great success
stories
end up here
i've been reporting on issues around
welfare in british gymnastics for the
past three years
when a group of parents came to me
concerned with what they saw as
failures of british gymnastics to
protect young
gymnasts but it's only this summer that
the true scale of these allegations have
become apparent
tens maybe even hundreds of athletes all
around the country
claiming they were the victim of
physical and emotional abuse
charlie fellows is one of them she was
among britain's best gymnasts
representing her country around the
world but she's scarred by her
experiences
and still struggles with body image
i had a day off and then i went in the
next day
and i was like 0.5 over the scales and i
remember having to go into the fitness
gym
it was constantly for about seven eight
hours for two days until i got
back down to the way that they wanted me
to get up
why they told me like i was too heavy to
train like i shouldn't be at that way
this is how like
injuries are gonna occur so if i'm not
this way then i won't be able to
train properly and achieve what i wanted
to achieve
in the 1970s and early 1980s
the soviet and romanian gymnasts
dominated
first came olga corbett nicknamed the
sparrow from minsk
then nadia commonetch who achieved the
first perfect 10
aged just 14. soon
coaches here were being dispatched over
there to watch how they did it
and in the early 1990s the first wave of
soviet and romanian coaches
began instructing in uk gyms
claire heather says her former coach was
among the first
we're talking about you know 10 year old
girls being pushed around by
a fully grown adult which was
really very scary and that was enough
really to kind of set the frame of the
rest of the abuse that took place
there was withdrawal of attention
um deliberately ignoring certain
gymnasts
and being a lot of being sent out the
gym or taking off bits of
equipment many of the world's best
gymnasts
including nadia commonetch were products
of the david training camp in romania in
1992
adrian stan was recruited from david to
be head women's national team coach at
british gymnastics
he's now head of coaching there's no
suggestion that stan himself was abusive
but this documentary the secret of dave
offers a glimpse into the way young
girls were treated there by other
coaches
individuals within british gymnastics
told me they believed that this way of
coaching was exported wholesale
the unparalleled expertise but sometimes
also
an eastern bloc brutality
emotional abuse belittling humiliation
and
being shouted out aggressively and
generalized
ongoing disappointment and
i think really it's the disappointment
that causes the
emotional turmoil all the years later
because
it did not matter what we did it was not
good enough
the aftermath of a dismal olympics for
team gb
in atlanta in 1996 prompted the
introduction of national lottery funding
british gymnastics is receiving 17
million
pounds for the cycle to the tokyo games
this pays for the upkeep of the national
training center in lillishaw
but some have unhappy memories of the
place
roxanne remembers starving herself to
prepare for a trip to lillish hall
she belonged to the south durham
gymnastics club
we used to run to the toilet before
getting weird we'd stand
outside the toilet waiting for others
jogging on the spot
like one last pathetic attempt to lose
weight
we'd strip down to just our leotard even
took out hair clips
hair clips and scrunchies so we would
just wear that little bit less
and like i was muscling but i wasn't fat
by any stretch the imagination
i was constantly made to feel
like i was and
then told i had to train in ankle
weights
so i would know next time that that's
how
it would feel if i put on weight i've
had issues with
weight and eaten ever since like
binge eating i've thrown up i've hidden
hidden my food when i've eaten it
roxanne's mum eileen says the parents
were manipulated too
the word i've used is groomed almost
brainwashed into believing
that this is elite sport this is elite
gymnastic because if these kids want to
do well which they did
this was necessary for them to do that
olympic bronze medalist amy tinkler also
says she was the victim of abuse at
south durham
she retired earlier this year still just
a teenager
blaming her traumatic experience at the
club for leaving the sport
the club categorically denies any
allegations of abuse
and mistreatment of any of its gymnasts
elite sport does take blood sweat and
tears
and it's the job of the coach to get the
best from the gymnast
they're also responsible for their
safety and excess weight can cause
injury
one former coach and sports psychologist
thinks coaches can become blinkered
gymnastics is a is a sport
where excellence is given a number and
therefore it's it's the notion of
perfectionism
and excellence and all the rest of it i
think particularly the mindset of the
elite
of the elite coaches it's about the
pursuit of that
i think they'd say in order to do this
to get to this place
this is what you have to go through that
control
doesn't just stop at way some of the
women i've spoken to have mentioned this
obsession
with every aspect of the way that they
look now you won't see this written in
the rule book but one former welfare
officer for british gymnastics told me
that before they go onto the competition
floor young gymnasts are advised to hike
their leotards up like they're in a
miley cyrus concert
in order to impress the judges claims of
bullying and fat
shaming are not just confined to
artistic gymnastics
mimi caesar represented england in
rhythmic gymnastics
i genuinely did think of myself what i
was told
constantly like you're not good enough
your thighs are disgusting
that leotard doesn't look right on you
because it doesn't pull you in um
and like moments where i'm at a
competition and
a one for example and then someone says
to you you thought it was a horrible
like there was nothing wrong with your
routine but your thighs
she was selected to be one of the poster
girls for the upcoming commonwealth
games in birmingham her home city but
mimi claims she was told
age 25 that she was past it
i have been told look to my face that it
is my age and i am too old
and that is the reason why i won't be in
a hotel for birmingham
it's not just girls either christian
norman was a promising young gymnast
but left the sport after he claims to
have suffered years of abuse from his
coach
he's now an academy footballer at
sunderland but finds it difficult to
talk about his gymnastics
it just got to the point where i was
always like scared to go jim
the name used to call christian was just
horrendous and anything was you know you
you're a gay boy
you know any move that you couldn't
quite get right or whatever it was
just man up your gay boy it was just
horrendous and knowing that he was going
through that for such a long time and
bottling it up and we didn't
necessarily realize the full extent of
what was going on anyway she was a
parent phil
just absolutely it must be oh
yeah yeah some years later or still it's
very very raw
yeah two years ago uk sport ordered what
they called a
culture check after an avalanche of
allegations around duty of care in other
olympic sports
from paris swimming to canoeing and
cycling to mention
just a few but these allegations around
gymnastics take us right to the present
day
leaving some to wonder what exactly have
these investigations achieved
it could be well into next year or
longer before there are any substantive
answers from the independent inquiry
into these abuse claims
but with several former gymnasts already
pursuing their own legal claims
change could be forced through sooner i
really do think
that there's been a culture within
gymnastics that has allowed people
in positions of power to get away
with abusive um actions and they've not
been facing any consequences
the relief for many lies in finally
finding a collective voice to call for
change
i didn't say anything i wouldn't just be
letting myself down i'd be letting
every other little one that wants to try
and make it as a rhythmic gymnast down
i don't want my gymnast to experience
what
i've had to gone through the thing that
i would like to come out of this is that
it becomes
normalized for women in their 20s and
30s to be able to compete at an
international level
from an antiquated past time to an
olympic winning machine
gymnastics in britain has until now been
in the ascendancy
but with the full weight of these abuse
allegations yet to land
we still don't know the true cost of
those medals
martha kellner sky news